so i want to re-address something i
demonstrated with you okay
so
uh we were doing the drill where you're
trying to touch my chest right boom
and i'm going and i am
working a mixture of ikea ankles
to get that
and you can see there that adhesion came
in okay
and then we said
that
you create that adhesion and sometimes
you lose the adhesion
because sometimes they try to pull off
of that adhesion so
you you can uh feel it right there okay
now just pull your hand back please say
it's off okay
um
but
let's go slowly i got two options that i
can do
even though it's on people will counter
you they want to fight you so they can
feel your your control so they just try
to pull off okay
one option was that you just follow the
hand in and you stay on it but i'm the
one following it so following is the
first one okay
and the second one is important so as
she's bringing this hand in
there's still another way of getting the
adhesion this way
do you see
[Music]
so
uh
let me just get the first one so let me
put you in it first you just stay where
you are okay
there it is you see right there and
you're gonna pull it back and i just
follow it in do you see
and let me get it again there it is
right there and you go back and i take
it this way
do you understand okay
um
you're doing that in this technique
or you're trying to
okay
um so
we're here and a lot of you lose the arm
all right
it's the same thing there's the adhesion
do you see
and she wants to bring her arm down
let's just go dead
just go dead there you go do you see
that oh that arm is going from here
to
there i have a couple options i can
follow it in
and i pick this up over here
or
as she's moving
as that arm's moving i am extending it
out with another adhesion you see
uh the other thing you can do in this
technique that is a little harder to do
in the other drill
is
i will actually use the other hand
to move her other arm into the adhesion
okay so
uh her arm is going dead you see and
i'll use this to move her
into the adhesion of the other hand you
see that and
that makes this kind of
stuff totally wrong i don't really have
the adhesion okay
so look for that and don't give up
okay don't give up
keep working it
so that you can keep it okay let's try
and win
okay so these internal skills are inlaid
in the um
keyhole nozzle but there's tactical
skills in the kihon waza so you want to
be in the back
okay
what i mean by that is i don't i don't
need the uh
the internal skills do not require the
external skills but external skills are
teaching us
okay so pull into the body into the body
and i get all the way to the back you
see
i'm all the way back here
this
you think is the back but it's not the
back of the rotating cross the back of
the rotating cross
is going to be on the other side of her
spine not on her spine here because as
soon as you start to rotate you see that
we're no longer in alignment
okay we're like two circles here and the
only way i can do it is what you guys
are doing
pull her into it
and then when i take her down i'm
actually in front of her okay
so
boom get all the way on the other side
of her and rotate with her you see
you're gonna rotate with her
boom
all the way
other side
okay let's try to do
there is a common thing i'm going to
show you what where what is going to
happen so i'm going to do it one way
okay
so i go here you see that foot
i made that foot a pivot point because
i'm not controlling his center you see
that
and now i'm just tilting him first of
all people in real life will not tilt
for you only aikido gymnast will do that
for you okay
uh so
you weren't in the center and that foot
does need to move you see that foot nope
nope you see okay when i come around
here i don't start turning here that
foot is going to move again
there it is
don't let it do what he wants to do okay
you're in his center everybody every uk
wants to do that because every new kid
is going to be a
self-centered that's why we're here
right so he's all like this is good
enough
that's your opportunity to go no it's
not good enough okay so that foot
keeps moving you see it's moving where i
need it to go
then the same thing
is once they
there's the same rookie that wants to
tilt here once they figure out where
they think you want them to fall they go
ahead and just take a dive and that's
another opportunity
you see he wanted to go belly down but i
made him go sideways okay
so control
control
sideways
because he's still descending and i'm
just making these micro adjustments as
he descends so he can't go belly down
and he can't teeter like this
okay uh
so tactically i have to stay in back of
her that's my that's where i want to be
okay
uh i find there's generally two foot
maneuvers that lend themselves toward
that
and i'll give you the easiest one the
easiest one
is uh
as she starts to turn
and i'm turning with her my centers my
spines with her spine i'm bringing her
forward into the technique
uh
and i stay in the back
and this foot is gonna go
okay
so i'm in this stance
so
watch for that we'll do the same side
the other one
is i don't even separate my feet i keep
turning
this way
okay
so play with either one
so i'm in the back back here okay uh
she's going to get up
and as she gets up you see i'm going
forward and then
it's the same thing
i'm controlling her incrementally
uh here
and she starts losing that arm
i'm sticking with it
moving the two hands going together she
gets up i'm bringing that in
[Music]
and i'm controlling
staying in
so right there go ahead i'm gonna keep
talking you're gonna do it but leah got
herself into that position
you can keep doing you leah
right here she got up on her own and
leaned herself backwards okay
and so that's where you don't have leah
you understand so uh
at this drill level what i want to see
is like i said she doesn't get to do
what she wants to do you see that so
even if leah got up i would change it
you see
you see how i did that so she wanted to
get up and go back
that's my opportunity to do something
else if you feel good okay so
um
it's not good enough to go here
and leah gets up bends backwards and
then i go
so
i see uh
you you have that center
you have this center then you have this
foot no no no we're all gonna move we're
all gonna move we're all gonna move
she's
[Music]
and i'm doing it with that same
creating that ikea adhesion towards
kazushi you get it and i don't really
care about the road tonight okay
all right
let's try it again